and Thank You mr. Stevens for your
generosity to the Academy library it's
really a priceless gift I also want to
thank Randy Hebert camp who does such an
incredible job for the Academy for
inviting me to to explore some of the
creative decisions that the filmmakers
made when they came together to give us
Alice Adams so let me just say right
here that the whole of my talk is just
one giant spoiler alert because it is
impossible to get into the creative
choices and Alice Adams without talking
about the famously contested ending of
the film and you may be theory that my
spoiler alert could ruin your evening
but my intention here is to do what the
George Stevens lecture was created to do
which is to illuminate the filmmaking
process and ask us to examine the true
value of our film culture it's easy to
dismiss Alice Adams as a depression-era
escapist comedy told by a group of
excellent craftsmen but stick with me
and we will discover that Alice Adams in
the world portrays remains surprisingly
contemporary the director George Stevens
and the lead actress Katharine Hepburn
were both dead set on having the sober
ending that was given in Booth
Tarkington novel however RKO studios and
specifically the producer pandro Berman
were with equal force committed to a
romantic conclusion as invented by the
screenwriter Dorothy Yost production
actually started without the ending
being resolved and as production
barreled along even as passionate memos
about the ending flew back and forth
between the producer and the director of
the star neither side was being
persuaded well to understand why the
endings of this film was so
controversial we should look first at
why our Kyah even wanted to make this
movie at all Booth Tarkington novel was
published actually in 1921 but no one
thought about adapting it to a film
until 14 years later so why this movie
now what was the
relevance to Alice Adams to 1935 today's
cartoon version of the Great Depression
has millionaires in tuxedos and spats
stepping off the ledges of their
apartment buildings or the office
buildings having lost everything
overnight in the stock market crash of
October 1929 but in fact the Great
Depression the financial markets didn't
collapse in a single precipitous dive
instead for several years the volatile
markets rocketed up and down and plunged
again in these dizzying cycles of peaks
and troughs that allowed wealthy
investors to actually greatly increase
their Treasuries through speculation in
the market but when banks and other
speculators got caught on the wrong side
of these risky market cycles entire
business sectors which just suddenly
collapse regular middle-class people
would suddenly find themselves forced
into unemployment and their savings
completely wiped out or if they were
lucky they'd be trapped at a low wage
job year after year unable to scrape
together the capital to even start a
business even as wealthy people in their
town continued to thrive well Alice
Adams father was that middle-class guy
trapped in a low-paying job that won't
allow him to advance he's 55 he's broke
he's too loyal to leave the firm that
his height that he's been working for
for decades and it's too late to start
over now anyway and because you know
who's gonna hire him as the story begins
Virgil has suffered some sort of fiscal
collapse it seems to vaguely like a
nervous breakdown
his wife urges Virgil to do something to
save the family from financial ruin in
their 22 year old daughter Alice sets
the movie's plot in motion when she
takes matters into her own hands and
arming herself with deceit tries to
launch herself into the moneyed social
class where she feels that her family
rightfully belongs well you can see the
wish fulfillment that this story would
offer at audiences in 1935 certainly RKO
s new head of production saw the
potential and early in 1935 pandro s
Berman commissioned
what the title-page calls an estimating
script prepared by a screenwriter Jane
Murphy which was essentially a direct
transference of the novel chapter by
chapter into scenes and dialogue this
document thanks to the George Stevens
family is the Academy's Margaret Herrick
library you can go look at it
it allowed Berman to see the shape and
tone of the film and also to estimate
the cost and it also allowed him to
attract his movie star before we go into
that we would do really have to talk
about pantera Berman I've gotten kind of
obsessed with him in March 1935 he had
just turned 30 years old five years
before he was a newbie at RKO
he was just hired to do film editing but
the first thing that happens to him is
that the supervising producer on a
particularly troubled films walks out
during production and young pandro has
to step into this guy's job to finish
the picture and then pretty soon after
that David O Selznick takes over RKO and
Sachs a bunch of people but he keeps
Pedro and he makes him his assistant
producer Selznick is 31 and Rho is 26 no
doubt Selznick system to parent role
along the lines of as they say today the
studio needs product but at any rate
Pandora's freshman move is to put a
dancer Fred Astaire together with
another dancer Ginger Rogers Fred
Astaire has been happily dancing with
his sister Adele so he initially resists
the shake-up but pandro is able to
convince Astaire to partner with Ginger
Rogers and in fact Berman has to
reconvince
Astaire every time they make a picture
every time the guy got up to dance with
Ginger Rogers no no that was the last
time so Astaire and Rogers do two movies
a year at RKO for a couple three years
all of which proved to be immensely
successful top-hat earns four Oscar
nominations and Selznick makes pandro
the head of production at RKO he's 29
years old right we know at least one
thing about pandro Burman at that
underaged he has a gift for recognizing
Talent
that year he spots a be movie actress
under contract at Warner Brothers and
arranges for RKO to use her on loan and
Somerset moms
of Human Bondage the critical acclaim
for Betty Davis and that film ignites
her career and makes her a movie star a
few years later Pedro will size up young
Orson Welles in greenlight Citizen Kane
he'll then cast Elizabeth Taylor in
National Velvet but before any of that
even before he launches Betty Davis
Berman cast a young and fairly green
Katharine Hepburn and her first leading
role in morning glory a movie about a
young actress who is date raped at 26
Hepburn wins her first Oscar for that
performance and pandro naturally starts
looking for something else were caved
like black morning milori something with
a little edge a little comedy something
that will speak to the times that we're
living through enter Alice Adams
initially as we've heard Hepburn and
Berman wanted George Cukor to direct
Cukor is busy with another picture he
says try William Wyler or this other
young director who's working at RKO is
directing these minor comedies George
Stevens with George's 29 as we've heard
and until now he's been kind of
sidelined shooting short films as a
cinematographer for Laurel and Hardy and
then directing these little comedies for
wheeler and Woolsey although William
Wyler has directed close to 20 feature
films as we have heard Hepburn and
pandro chose Stevens which by far was
the riskier choice you're young and
foolish you know what can I say all
right both but the interesting thing was
that he may not have talked much in his
first interview but Katharine Hepburn
and George Stevens connected over Alice
Adams they both love the way that the
Torkington novel ends which is also how
the April 5th estimating script Anton's
well here comes the spoiler that I
promised you in the book Alice Adams
adopts a false high society persona to
attract a wealthy young suitor Arthur
played by Fred MacMurray and
as the courtship develops Arthur begins
hinting about marriage and Alice gets
pressured into inviting him home to meet
her parents her deceptions about her
impoverished family of course get
exposed and Alice breaks up with Arthur
at the end of the book Alice enrolls in
business school choosing to escape
poverty by working instead of pretending
to be what she isn't when George is
tapped to be director he oversees
screenwriter Dorothy Yost as she's
working on the production draft of Alice
Adams which is loosely based on the
estimating script at this point Dorothy
has more than 40 screenwriting credits
she is by far the most seasoned member
of that team but georgeson's daily notes
to Dorothy and describes a final scene
for the movie in which Alice goes to
business college on her way to class she
runs into Arthur who he hasn't seen
since she broke up with him he's
embarrassed but he asked if he might
call on her sometime and she gives a
cordial yes and then walks into the
school with no plan on following up on
this so this is George's suggested
ending however even as the director is
giving Dorothy notes about the ending
she is apparently hearing entirely
contradictory notes from the producer at
the studio has anyone here a freedman in
that situation given that her paycheck
reads RKO at the top Dorothy writes and
ending in which Arthur forgives Alice
for her deceptions tells her he loves
her he sweeps her into a kiss and that's
the Hollywood ending that pandro Berman
wants but George Stephenson Kate Hepburn
hate that ending Pando is worried about
trying to in the movie any other way
Catherine insists on bringing in a
friend of hers a novice screenwriter
Morty oftener who until recently had
been working as a photographer pandro
allows oftener to make some changes in
the script under the direction of George
but Pedro box at George and after going
back to this business school ending tip
Andrew it seemed severe in the final
pages of the book
Tarkington compares Alice Adams decision
to go to business college to that of a
young woman quote taking the veil after
a deathblow to
love which you don't need pander Oberman
to tell you is a far cry from arthur's
sweeping alice into a kiss
so Hepburn and Berman are the two
screenwriters receive a long impassioned
memo from Berman making a case for the
sort of ending that he senses the
audience needs to see the lives of most
are the lives of Alice and her family
Pandora writes Alice and her family
suffered through so much of the picture
he describes Stevenson heparins
preferred ending as a dangerous irritant
to an audience waiting to be rewarded
and made more hopeful biologically happy
ending pandro finishes having suffered
they will naturally want release and a
new hope to take with them as they leave
the theatre to offer these people only a
philosophy that life goes on will not
content the American public in its
present temper after years of depression
well the ending of the film that you'll
see tonight wasn't in the script until
12 days before the picture wrapped in
his pleading memo to Hepburn and
Stephens and the two writers you can
feel how outnumbered young pandro feels
as he adds a postscript PS I have on
several occasions allowed George Cukor
to run in some of the rushes with me
which he has raved about as being most
charming and most human and in as much
as I think his opinion is respected by
all of us I would like to note that he
feels from what he is seen on the screen
that it would not only be bad box office
to have the girl not get the man in the
picture but it would also be the wrong
ending and actually wrong ending is I
scribbled a margin note in pencil
diplomatically airbrushing the words
that Berman actually typed first which
were it would make a bad picture
artistically well in another memo Bert
Berman lays out the pros and cons for
what he calls the happy ending and the
unhappy ending and given that he very
much wants to appease his unhappy ending
inclined movie star K Hepburn pandro
does make a valiant attempt to be
even-handed
asserting that Allis going to business
college rounds out her character and
that she has learned to stand alone she
is heroic in her sacrifice she has
gained in the spirit though she has lost
in the material world he warns that such
an ending might not have box office
appeal but tempers that by flattering
his movie star miss Hepburn is at her
best in unusual different in daring
roles he then goes on for the next five
pages to demolish those arguments saying
the unhappy ending does not offer
dignity save that which comes from a
sacrifice and resignation socially Alice
will now be completely out of all the
world she had hoped to enter well what
was this world that Alice had hoped to
enter what the film Telegraph's about
that world is this the upper class is
white the lower class is black and
Alice's family teachers in between is
this just me looking at 1935 through a
21st century lens in a revisionist way I
don't think so
I think that you will see that Steven's
make sure that we grasp that class
divide immediately in the third or
fourth shot of the film a very opening
of the film when we meet Alice she is
emerging from a 10 cent store she is
preceded by a heavyset african-american
woman and her children who were
conspicuously eating messy ice cream the
script describes Alice as shielding
herself behind this family so that no
one will see that Alice is leaving the
five and time Alice thing quickly ducks
into the doorway of a posh shop next
door pretending that she's shopping
there for the society party that she
will attend that evening well Alice is
escorted to that party by her unwilling
brother Walter who is as unvarnished and
blunt as Stanley Kowalski he mortifies
Alice in front of her friends by openly
chatting up the african-american
bandleader who turns out to be
shockingly Walters friend Alice tries to
put a different gloss on Walter when her
new beau Arthur later finds her brother
gambling with the black
coatroom attendance Alice lies to arthur
saying that our artistic brother is only
gathering material for the amusing [ __ ]
stories that he writes blackness
signifies a lower place than the place
Alice is desperately trying to cling to
as she creates a fictional self and a
fictional social status to make herself
worthy of Arthur Russell's attentions
Booth Tarkington novel was published
deep into the Jim Crow years in 1921 the
same year is the explosive Tulsa riot it
sets the tone of casual racism that we
also encounter in the film Alice Adams
in the novel as in the film blackness is
presented solely for Laughs I bring this
up to prepare you for the tension the
feeling of tension that arises when we
stand in the 21st century looking at the
cultural values of 1935 on full display
in the film that we are about to see
toward the end of act 2 under pressure
from her mother Alice invites Arthur to
dinner hoping to pull off some sort of
Jedi mind trick that will make Arthur
blind the shabby 'no the family's home
alice and her mother hire a maid to wait
table that evening the disastrous
servant who shows up that night in the
middle of a heat wave is Hattie McDaniel
an actor who four years later will
become the first african-american to be
nominated for and win an Oscar for her
role in Gone with the Wind if you can
look past the minstrel show caricature
that had a MacDonald was given to play
in Alice Adams you will see a great
actress at work as well as a great
director behind the camera oddly enough
the maids comic turns are only vaguely
described in the screenplay very sketchy
and yet the movie requires that the
character be funny and every scene in
looking at Tarkington novel now it's
clear that Hattie McDaniel went to the
book for guidance her creative choices
beat after beat draw from the Smith the
specific descriptions that we find in
Tarkington STOVL when we see a fine
actress like mcdeere
you're laboring under these old
stereotypes it's good to remind
ourselves how had he viewed her job
the only choice permitted us she said is
either to be servants for $7.00 a week
or to portray them for 700 a week and
I'd rather make 700 a week but here is
the amazing thing as I stand in the 21st
century looking at a film made 83 years
ago what I am most struck by isn't this
racial dissonance it's the portrait of
Alice Adams which seems tailor-made for
the curated lifestyle here's my selfie
fake it till you make it follow me on
YouTube zeitgeist of 2018 and
contemporary parlors kate heparins Adams
Adams is fronting at all times
performing her received ideas of both
the femininity and class Alice is a
genius of gesture and artificiality we
watch her bestow false cheer on her
family and a false persona on herself
and we marvel at the fluidity of her
lies and cover stories Hepburn handles
all of that with perfect charm you're
completely on her side for this woman
who is lying constantly through her
teeth all the while giving an absolutely
harrowing performance that guides her
character's secret core of unbearable
shame and self rejection
yet even as we're finding all of that
fairly disturbing Hepburn and George
Stevens managed to keep afloat the
illusion that we're watching a comedy as
for whether the filmmakers picked the
right ending I have only this to guide
us the protagonist changes that is one
of the principles of screenwriting those
changes come about through the
characters own actions
that's another principal who's been
writing the characters suffering rises
from their own actions as the
protagonist contends with something
inside themselves and that something
must shift must be dealt with for the
protagonists deep
desire to be fulfilled at the end of the
story all of these are basic tenets of
drama is given by Aristotle's Poetics
what Alice Adams is contending with is
that secret core of shame she begins by
blaming her father
if only father made more money I could
be happy but by the end exhausted by the
effort of relentless deception and
knowing that by her prefer perpetual
pretence she alone has destroyed any
hope of future with Arthur Ellis drives
her happiness
Arthur away Ellis has to stand in the
aftermath of that it acknowledged her
mistakes to herself and then to her
family as Alice says to her mother in
the novel when she's preparing to go to
business school isn't it about time for
thinking for me I mean that's the
inevitable but surprising ending the
targetted provides for fake it till you
make it
Alice Adams and in terms of drama that's
the truthful ending the ending that
Alice earned through her actions you may
disagree you may see that easier
romantic turn at the end of the film
tonight and you may find yourself
aligned with Pandora Berman who
rightfully felt that during a brutal
economic crisis a sober introspective
ending was the last thing that a movie
audience wanted to see owning up to
their part in their suffering would be
for a later time right now they just
needed to survive their sorrows we're
going to screen the film now enjoy it
and I look forward to the wonderful
discussions that I'll get to overhear as
we leave the theater tonight thank you
so much for being here